I’m Whitney Pennington Rodgers,
I’m TED’s current affairs curator.
And the guest who's joining us now
is not only a psychologically
wise leader himself,
but he looks to develop
psychologically wise leaders
to put them out into the world.
From 2001 to 2018, he was the CEO
and chairman of American Express,
and now he is the managing director
and chairman of General Catalyst,
a venture capital firm
which seeks to develop organizations
that put out positive change
into the world.
He's also the cofounder of OneTen,
which is a coalition of leading executives
who have joined together
to upskill, hire and advance
one million Black Americans in 10 years.
Please welcome Ken Chenault.
Thank you for being here.
Ken Chenault: It's great to be here.
WPR: You have a quote that you often say:
"The role of a leader is to define
reality and give hope."
In this time that we're living in,
with COVID and massive changes
in the workforce,
how do you think
about this idea of change,
and how does this quote apply to that?
KC: The question is, how can you give
people concrete reasons,
and also inspiration to be hopeful.
And in uncertain times,
I think what's very important
is the leader has to be grounded
in some core values.
Because, to me, what’s most
critical about leadership
and leading in uncertain times --
and I would emphasize that I think
anyone at any level can be a leader,
in their business,
civic life, personal life --
and what they have to recognize
is if you want to lead,
you have to be willing to serve.
So you've got to have
that servant leadership mentality.
But what you have to do
is stand for something.
And organizations are guided
by values and behaviors.
That's the way you're creating a culture.
And so in a time of uncertainty,
what do you need to do?
One is you need to give people context.
What's happening?
You can admit that you're anxious,
that there are reasons,
in fact, to be nervous.
But what's important
is you need to emphasize to people
the reasons why you think
that we can get to the other side.
WPR: Could you talk a little bit
about your work now
and what is General Catalyst,
what are you looking to do
with that organization?
KC: General Catalyst
is a venture capital firm,
and we're very focused
on building companies.
What's important
is the philosophy of General Catalyst,
which brings a level of intentionality,
which is we want to invest
in powerful, positive change
that will endure.
So our view is, the paradigm,
sometimes, that's presented,
which is you have to choose
between profits,
investment returns
and social good.
And we believe that’s a false choice.
That, in fact, technology
should be a great enabler.
But the reality is "What's the intention?"
WPR: I love this idea
of "responsible innovation,"
and I'm interested to know
what the impetus was
for you to really focus in this space.
Were you not seeing enough
of this happening?
KC: I would say
there were several reasons.
One is, as I decided in stepping down
from American Express,
of “What would I do next?”
One, it was very clear to me
from all of my experiences
is that technology was the great enabler,
and could be.
But I thought we needed to have a force
that was acting in a more responsible way.
I also frankly thought that technology
was not diverse enough,
when I looked at the whole sector
of technology and venture capital
and private equity.
But what was really attractive to me
was that my partners
believed very strongly
in this notion of responsible innovation,
and they were willing to do
what it takes to embrace it.
And let me be clear,
we're in the early stages of this.
But one of the things
I'm very proud of, for example,
is what we've been able
to do in health care,
where we're actually partnering
with health care systems.
So, we're partnering
with nonprofit entities,
and our objective is not to disrupt
and blow up the health care system,
it's to innovate and transform
the health care system as a partner.
And so it's recognizing
that our objective in health care
is to provide high-quality,
lower-cost health care
to all segments.
And technology can be
a great enabler in doing that.
And in addition to that --
it's not an either-or --
we believe that we're going to generate
very attractive returns,
which is important if we're building
enduring businesses.
WPR: This idea of putting people first
as you're developing your technology,
but it's not just about people --
you’re thinking about responsibility
in terms of the environment,
responsibilities to communities.
Could you talk more about that?
KC: What's critical here, fundamentally,
what I have always believed
and certainly have articulated
over the last 30 years,
is companies exist
because society allows us to exist.
And so we have
a responsibility to society.
When we're developing
products and services,
shouldn't we think about who is in,
who are we serving,
and who might be negatively impacted
by a product or service
that we're offering.
As we're building companies,
let's start at the beginning and say,
"How do we build a more diverse
workforce in that company?"
"How are we thinking
about the environment?"
So what's very important is,
we can do a form, if you will,
of social due diligence,
side by side with the financial
due diligence.
But what's important is,
as we're building companies today,
let's have a broader mindset.
Let's have a higher level
of intentionality.
And no one, I think, most people --
obviously, there's some exceptions --
start off building a company, saying,
"I want to build a company
that will hurt people."
WPR: Right.
KC: But that's not enough.
What you've got to say is,
"My intention is to build a company
that will address
the following set of issues."
And actually, I want to,
from the beginning,
build a company that will have
a positive impact on society,
as well as generate attractive economics.
Now that's simple,
but it is hard,
and people need guidance,
people need the tools,
and that's what we're trying to do
with responsible innovation.
WPR: I'd like to pivot for a second
to another organization
that you're championing,
that's really important to you,
which is OneTen.
You're the cofounder of this initiative
that looks to put more Black Americans
into sustainable careers.
Tell us a little bit
about how OneTen came about.
KC: So OneTen came about literally
the day after the murder of George Floyd.
And Ken Frazier,
who was a former CEO of Merck,
is still executive chairman of Merck,
but is also now chairman
of Healthcare Assurance Initiatives
for General Catalyst.
Obviously, we were devastated
about what happened.
And back to defining reality
and giving hope, we said,
"The reality of the situation
is that Black Americans
who do not have a college degree
are a segment of our population
that we need to address
in a more comprehensive way."
And what we said
is we want to do something
that is really impactful and enduring.
And we think the private sector,
particularly large companies,
need to take a more active role.
And so we talked about what we could do.
If you look at the facts,
80 percent of the jobs
60,000 dollars and above
in companies
require a four-year college degree.
Now the reality is ...
that a substantial majority of those jobs
do not require a college degree.
And so, it serves --
You talk about structural,
systemic racism.
What happens is it just knocks out
a large population.
And the reality is skills-first
is what we should be focused on.
And I want to be clear:
I want as many people to go to college
as can go to college.
But to be successful,
to have a family-sustaining job,
should not mean
that you have to go to college.
And so what we decided
is we wanted companies to embrace that.
We had 60 companies sign up
with hard financial commitments
and a commitment to jobs.
And here's what I think
is exciting, Wendy,
is that people are recognizing,
because you're looking
at the jobs, they're saying,
"Well, a lot of these jobs
don't require a college degree."
And so here we have an initiative
that is geared to Black Americans.
But at the end of the day,
it's going to end up
benefiting all Americans,
because the jobs, the specifications,
the requirements are going to change.
So in our society,
where we have a win-loss mentality,
by focusing on this issue,
we actually have opened the aperture
of opportunity for everyone.
So we are making progress.
And I really think that our objective
is, in 10 years, to have created
a million family-sustaining jobs.
WPR: So OneTen
is one million jobs in 10 years.
KC: In 10 years.
You know, simple, objective --
not easy, right?
Because part of what we're doing
is the challenge of matching
supply and demand,
the skilling, the reskilling,
all of that, that has to take place.
The job supply network is very fragmented.
So we've got to put that together.
So what I think you're seeing
is I look at OneTen --
"That's a start-up."
But we are mission-driven,
we are outcome-driven,
and we're going to achieve that objective.
WPR: That feels like a great place to end.
Thank you so much, Ken, for sharing
all of this insight and wisdom.
I feel like I've learned so much.
I know that everyone watching
has probably learned a lot, too.
KC: Thank you so much.
I enjoyed the conversation.
WPR: Thank you.